a controversial ban on wearing religious
symbols has been passed in a Canadian
province for some people working in the
public sector lawmakers have called the
move the right to have secular public
services and separate State on religion
now the legislation will affect
government employees police some
teachers for example and will apply to
Muslim headscarfs
Jewish skull camps and other various
symbols last-minute changes to the bill
also included the introduction of
inspectors who will be tasked with
ensuring people abide by the new law but
some in Quebec have criticized the move
for violating basic rights the Prime
Minister has once again suggested that
Quebec values are incompatible with
fundamental rights the 16th of June 2019
is a very set date that has just entered
the history books of Quebec a date that
will forever mark a vision of Quebec
that divides rather than brings together
that excludes rather than includes that
stigmatizes
rather than reconciles will there be
police officers going after people to
check if they have religious signs we
don't know it's not clear we didn't even
have time to analyze his modification
clearly they did it in a very
undemocratic way okay for a little more
depth on this we spoke to university
lecturer dr. Oren almaty and traumas
patron the leader of the Canadian
nationalist party down the rabbit hole
we go because what is religious and what
it's not I tend to believe that politics
and religion are intertwined necessarily
to a certain degree and at the end of
the day when you say wedding rings could
be seen as a religious symbolism the
next step after that could be the
apparel people we're not just talking
about face veils but the the dresses
women wear or the clothes men wear and
what this is really pointing to is a
Quebec that is known in Canada to be
fierce about protecting their identity
and that is why the Quebec voters voted
in a nationalist populist government
with the caq
and right now as the premier mr.
legality himself says they're getting
exactly what they voted for well the
problem is whenever you're prevented
from doing something that you feel that
you should have the right to do or that
something that's so important to you on
a very fundamental level like as
something as many was Muslim to say
about the religion you are really
setting it up for a lot of I think both
demonstrations and likely physical
clashes because people believe that
their existence is on the line and they
feel that they are justified to use any
means necessary to fight for what they
feel is their right so when anybody
feels that their rights are being taken
away from them then we can expect there
to be as I said I think physical clashes
and it's gonna all be under the rubric
or the guise of Islamophobia they're
going to say it's a blatant attack
against a particular group and and when
you're fighting for that cause this has
you know potential ramifications
globally where people say oh we thought
Canada was such a welcoming diverse
country but it seems that at least part
of it Quebec is Islamophobic and who
knows what kind of repercussions we can
expect moving forward when people from
other countries might decide to make a
statement beyond a simple protest
you